good morning
first item on the agenda so welcome
everybody
and we have apologies for absence
have we received any apologies for
absence
okay so we'll move on to the next item
which is declarations of interest
so if we have any members who have any
uh
interest to declare this is the time to
do it on any of the items that we are
discussing on the agenda today any
declarations of interest
you know okay
so the minutes of last meetings that's
pages four to five
and to approve as correct to approve
them as correct so are we
happy to approve them as correct
are there any questions from any members
no oh yeah
so if you if you want to speak can you
just speak because i'm i'm
actually using my screen from the agenda
so i don't see everybody
straight away so if you want to speak
just state your name and then
put your microphone on if that's okay
yep
hello uh cat thank you um
i'm not sure if it's a bit of a
follow-up we got the
um gender statistics pay gap
passed on to us and i just wonder
whether it'd be possible to have a bit
better
explanation of what all the numbers mean
uh where we were last year and if we
have a target
on that and how we're faring with
other authorities or whatever the
comparisons are please
so a bit more meat on the bones of those
statistics is that possible please
uh yeah i mean at this point uh are you
uh referring to the minutes of last
meeting
because at this point all we're doing is
we agreeing whether or not not the
accurate
sorry chair i'm jumping the gun yeah i i
will i will do that
i'm sorry could you repeat that sorry
i'm jumping the gun a bit i apologize i
i i do agree that they are accurate okay
all right thank you very much okay so we
all agree that the minutes are accurate
thank you the next item
on the agenda
is the impact of pandemic
update from the hr manager and that's a
verbal update
so if i could please ask
sarah thank you thank you very much
thank you
yeah i'm just going to give you a brief
update
on where we are at the moment um so
um since the pandemic um commenced
and we went into lockdown on the 24th of
march we have had
no um employees test positive
and during that period of time we have
had
96 employees who are self-isolated
and 27 employees um
who have shielded the shielding has now
come to an end that came to an end on
the 1st of august
um and in terms of those home working
and we did them send out some
information to ask employees to confirm
if they were home working or a hybrid or
a mixture um
in terms of coming into the office and
homework and so we just asked
um regarding their workstation set up
and how things were going at home and
overall
the response um has been positive and
we received responses from 155 employees
and that information went back through
to
hr and through directly to the manager
as well
so the manager has all the information
that their team members
um completed regarding that there were
some issues identified with workstation
set up such as the chair
and the screen and ict equipment
um and just being aware of the risk
protocols if they were coming into the
office
so we've had a couple of service
managers forums
um during the last couple of months
where we've gone over the guidance again
um where information is stored so that
it is accessible to them and just to
explain the expectations in terms of
those coming into yahoo sunday's working
from home as well
make sure that we are giving um sound
advice and guidance and looking after
employee welfare during this period
we are due to produce next week the
latest um
sickness absence um information
um so hopefully we'll have some more um
data on that to be able to compare it to
the last quarter where we saw a
significant decrease in sickness
absence um and we're just in the process
of uh re-looking at the the workplace
measures that were put in place at the
very beginning of
lockdown because they were put in place
um
on the basis of being a short-term
arrangement but now we're having to look
over along the term
so that's things like flexi time um
booking holidays um annual leave
and all about the guardians to do with
self-isolation and what if children get
sent home from school
do you need to self-isolate et cetera so
um i had a meeting with the directors
last week about that
and the guidance will hopefully be
coming around shortly following
consultation with trade unions
so that's the update for me from the
moment but happy to answer any questions
do we have any questions from members
yeah chicken can i ask a couple of
questions sarah yep
councillor funnel yeah yeah morning
sarah
sarah just a couple of questions the the
council has an homeworking policy anyway
in place before
copied how many people were actually
working from home
before the co-read epidemic started
the second question is second question
when the
council went into lockdown when we all
went into lockdown to work from home
how many of the council employees work
from home at that stage
and the third question same theme how
many people
currently are working from home in the
council today
okay um just to answer it it's quite a
difficult one to actually actually
because we do
we did have a homework in policy in
place but what we've discovered is quite
a lot of managers put in place ad hoc
arrangements because
there is difference between someone
being contractually
um to work at home as their base
uh contractually being a home worker and
then just the ad hoc arrangements
for home workers so um during the course
of this period we have come across the
some arrangements that have been put in
place with managers and employees
regarding that so in terms of giving
a figure on the number of home workers
it will be
prior to lockdown it will be a handful
that were contracted they were mainly in
the contact center
um and those are the only ones i'm aware
that were contracted
to work at home um i can find out that
figure
exactly for you um over the course of
the lockdown period
those that have been homework and that's
fluctuated
and so to begin with and we were asking
managers to complete
a weekly um return sheet to tell us the
working arrangements within their teams
but that was more for monitoring
staffing levels to make sure service
delivery was happening
um so i i in terms of i can
what i can do is i can look back and get
an average figure for you
um because it will vary each week
because a lot of staff
also went on to hybrid arrangements so
some
time working at home but also sometime
in the office as well maybe one day a
week two days a week
in terms of the numbers working at home
now that is something that we are asking
managers to confirm um and there is a
home working group been set up and i've
been asked to wait for that group
to complete their work before i go out
and and get that exact figure
um because i asked the question as to
whether i could do that last week but i
got asked
do you wait until that um home working
group goes out and collects all that
information
um based on the responses received we're
probably
looking at um i would say
a third up to half the staff home
working but now there's much more hybrid
arrangements in place so lots of rotor
arrangements
to enable stuff to come back into work
as well as undertaking some homework
so unfortunately i can't give you
definitive figures because it changes
all the time depending on if
somebody should office to allow them to
undertake their work
so they might have a week in the office
and then a week home working
or vice versa so there is lots of
different arrangements
um currently in place just to meet
service needs and managers have got the
discretion
to manage those in our teams
okay thanks so just one follow-up
question to that
in the in the protocol it asks all
employees of the home working to
complete
a weekly home working sheet yes
so is that being done yes so that is
being saved bit like people's flexi
sheets
any days worked at home they fill in a
reconciliation
sheet to let their manager know what
they've undertaken at home and then the
manager can log each week to see
the tasks that have been completed at
home so yes
based on the feedback we've had from all
managers employees are saving those into
their shared folders
and for the managers to be able to
access each week
okay thank you okay thank you
could i ask councillor uh birkin and
jones to uh uh
turn their switch off the microphone off
if you
if you don't mind because i'm getting a
lot of background noise
thank you any other questions
dear councillor birkin
thank you chair um obviously one of the
things that we're
looking at with the home working policy
is whether it's being applied properly
and
correctly um with sarah saying that they
found there were some ad hoc
arrangements uh i'm a bit concerned as
to what the
ad hoc possibly interpretations of the
homeworking policy will be
um hash any views on that please
um yes we're currently reviewing the
home working policy at the moment
because what
transpired is some employees have got
into the mindset
that every wednesday they were to work
at home because that
suited them um and they'd come to that
agreement with their line manager what
we were starting to see was a bit of a
creep
um with that in terms of people thinking
that that was an entitlement and a right
and what um the council was just doing
with resetting expectation from that
perspective to say that
um homework needs to be flexible to meet
the needs of the service as well so if
you have got
a meeting or an appointment with
somebody on the day that you
believe you traditionally homework
expectation was that you would change
your arrangements to
um accommodate that so those are the
kind of ad hoc arrangements that we were
finding that people seem to think they
either set their home working and that
was them set in stone
and so it was just about resetting
expectations there to say that yeah
we'll try and accommodate that if it
works for the service but we've got to
have flexibility on both sides really
with that and if
there is a requirement to be in the
building that day then you know that is
part of your contract of employment in
order to carry out your job role
okay uh i have a couple of questions for
me unless anybody else got any questions
no okay so my questions as you mentioned
obviously the sickness absence been
significantly uh down over the last
quarter so could
could you just give us a reminder of
what that figure is
just bear with me a second so i haven't
got it in front of me i just got to get
it up on my computer
okay i'll ask you the next question
okay um so how
are we doing a bit of a
survey on how that why that is obviously
uh with regard to sickness absence there
will be all sorts of things people still
working at whom
even if they don't feel if they feel a
bit unwell because they don't
have to travel and sometimes so
traveling that is the main issue when
you're feeling pooling
uh because if you're not really really
poorly if you've got a cold or anything
like that
you feel that you can still do some uh
reduced uh
duties so completely understand that but
are we as an
organization doing a proper survey on
why that is
and to find out the the exact reasons
why that sickness absence has gone down
because we want to learn from that how
can we
uh uh help keep that figure down
going forward and my next question is
about redeployment
uh during the login period there was a
number of
our staff being redeployed two other
duties
i just wondered how many of our staffs
were redeployed
the other question is uh what sort of
issues were
encountered especially with the trade
unions at that time because we haven't
got any report on that which i thought
we were going to get
with uh with the impact of the pandemic
that should be included in that
and also at the moment do we still have
people being redeployed
okay um thank you so
just to cover the sickness substance to
begin with so the figure for
last quarter um it was 1.17 days
um absence now in comparison to the
previous year it was 2.28 days
so it has dropped um significantly but
what we did see was an increase in
short-term absence over long-term
um sickness absence so um
this month at this quarter it'll be
interesting to see if the figures have
stayed there or thereabouts or we have
experienced an increase
um and as soon as i have that
information i'll make sure that goes
forward on forwarded on to you so you do
have that detail and
that comparator um in terms of
the reasons behind that decrease in
sickness absence
it is something that we are looking into
and is going to form part of this
larger corporate home working group and
to have a look into the reasons why the
husband had increased
decrease but i think you're right it
will be because people are able to stay
at home
so they might not be fully uh you know
fit
but they feel that they are able to work
from home um
you know there will be the decreased
interaction with other people
that's been experienced during this
period so um
i know with all the children going back
to school a lot of people have now got
calls
um so that has had an impact in terms of
the
you know the children not being at
school as well um
and also um being able to manage your
time a bit more flexibly
and to some extent has helped people as
well during this period
but it is something that we need a bit
more analysis on
just have a look at also for the
frontline staff who haven't remained at
work because their sickness levels
remain steady
and is it the you know the home workers
and the office-based staff where we've
actually seen that massive
decrease so when we get the next
quarters figures
and as part of this corporate home
working group that would form part of
that project plan for that so yeah it's
a point to look into so so that'd be uh
quite interesting for this this
committee to get to the report
itself once you've you've done it i
think all of us will
agree that we would want to see that to
kind of
work towards our uh end reports
next may uh councillor jones
so did you want me to answer the
question on redeployment
yes sorry yeah that's okay it's
absolutely okay councillor jones but it
goes through that to the next question
yeah just on redeployment yes and
several members of staff were redeployed
to the community response work
um and some of the leicester staff were
also redeployed into the contact center
uh as well to help deal with the number
of calls that were coming
through um so i can get your exact
figures
um i'm thinking it's around 20 to 30
that were redeployed
um and um they helped out on a range of
things really such as the pharmacy
deliveries the food deliveries um
and you know assisting with things where
the council needed support really in
taking things out to
to individuals and back as well so
sometimes they were supporting the ict
team and getting uh you know equipment
backing them
and and sorted where updates were
required so a range of things was
undertaken really
um and some staff then went back to
their um
substantive job roles so such as the
environmental health and planners as
their work started to increase
and then we asked other members of staff
um if they were able to support with the
community response work as well so
there has been quite a range of
individuals involved in that there's
nobody currently redeployed
um into other areas of work at the
moment
and the support from the uh trade unions
because obviously
as councillors we during lockdown uh
there was
quite a lot of rumors going around but
we never had actual
uh access to any other information
obviously
a cabinet member would have had the
proper access and the then leader
will have that that so any feedback from
you
yes in terms of the trade unions overall
they were um very positive and work with
us during this period of time
and we dealt with them mainly in my
experience on
um dealing with particular individual
cases and how guidance and advice should
be applied in those areas so whether
someone should
self-isolate whether they should have
done we've got people who
wanted to come to work but under the
self
isolation rules there was queries as to
whether they should
whether appropriate risk assessments and
working arrangements have been put in
place for individuals
so there was lots of different scenarios
and queries to deal with and it's
applying
all those situations and factors into
what would be the most appropriate
response and
approach to take and there were some
challenges with the trade unions
particularly within street scene
and you'll probably be aware um
regarding the
green bin collections that was um taken
off for a short period of time
um and it's a difficult one because
there
is often seen um a is a difference
between
uh frontline depot based staff and
office workers and
at the deputy what they saw was all the
office workers home working um
and able to stay at home whereas they
had to come out and continue to work as
normal
and perceptions on that can you know
have an influence on how individuals
feel
and but there are also other members of
staff such as the contact center
uh and other teams who had to continue
to work as normal as well
from council building so um i think
it was a learning process for everybody
and there were some as i say some
challenges with the trade unions
but often it was just a case of
discussing and chatting that through and
you know getting the facts of the
situation rather than the rumors that
might have been circulating
around regarding particular situations
so it was hard to react
as quickly to the ever-changing guidance
as well and that was
difficult because people were coming
towards coming to the trade union rep
saying
can i have an answer to this can i have
an answer to that and you don't
you didn't have time to process um
things because the gunners
and government announcements were coming
out very quickly and then you have to
kind of
give yourself time to sit down and work
through what would be the best approach
so that
everybody is treated fairly according to
their circumstances
and there was a corporate approach taken
rather than just
ad hoc um you know approaches taken so
it was
uh you know an interesting time but
overall
largely trade unions and in the council
have worked well together
thank you very much any other questions
for sarah
yeah counselor maggie imagings
just a small point really um when people
were
um ill during the pandemic
i think a lot of people were very stoic
and it was also very difficult to get
appointments with doctors
and things like that and hospital
appointments so a lot of people
who may have been signed off by doctors
probably weren't i don't think it would
make a big
difference to you figures but it is
another part of it
yeah yeah you are quite correct there
and and we know employees now are still
struggling to
get um appointments with their gp
and and feedback on um you know their
health conditions
to enable us to support them at work as
well so that is an ongoing challenge
and that we are experiencing at the
moment and it does cause some worry and
anxiety for employees if you aren't able
to get that that medical advice
and support and particularly around the
covered um
issues sometimes employees are
experiencing conflicting advice as well
so
they come and ask us um you know about
what they should and shouldn't do
because
um you know over the last couple of
weeks people have struggled to get a
test and it's
um you know really important that people
do have access to that information so
that they know
um what they should and shouldn't do and
they are getting the right advice
and as an employer we are finding that
we are
having to assist employees and with that
on an increasing basis really
angelique can i ask one more question
yeah sarah you said i think it was about
30 percent of
employees have been home working doing
television
have you noticed any deterioration in
service delivery or business performance
or has that been maintained
um the feed the fact that we've had um
is that that has been maintained
i think alternative approaches have been
applied to delivering services
but as things over the last couple of
months have started to change
a bit um it'd be interesting really just
to review where we are with that
and how services are are um you know
performing at the moment
um but i've not heard anything to say
that a service
isn't um delivering what it should it
just might be using a different way to
deliver
um the service that it it previously um
used to apply but
it's something that we'd have to ask or
managers just to give some feedback on
so
it might be worth asking you know the
directors on that because they would
have the overall
um information back um from the senior
management team
in terms of service performance but i'm
not aware of any particular
issues or concerns okay thank you
lovely and yeah councillor berkin and
then we'll move on to the next item
because what we've got some interviews
to do today so
uh councillor birkin yeah thank you
chair um
i hope i'm not jumping the gun again so
i'll try to be brief as we're looking at
the application of the policy
could serve against some statistics as
to how many requests
for homework were made in the last year
how many
instructions from the from the council
were given to instruct people to
homework last year
and to ensure equality what was the
range of jobs
male female or disabled in both those
areas please
and i know we've got to look at that
sometime whether this is the spot
or the next hyphen on the agenda uh i'm
not sure
it is the next item on the agenda one of
them
and but what i suggest is uh are you
okay to
answer this question anyway because it's
linked to what we're looking at
anyway uh and then we'll move on to the
next item councilor berkin and then
we'll
take things back back on sarah
um yeah overall prior to lockdown we
didn't have lots of requests for home
working home working
um usually transpired as a result maybe
if someone being on long-term sickness
absence and it facilitated a return to
work
so overall i i can't think of
um any requests that we have prior to
lockdown for home working
obviously on the evening of the 23rd of
march
um into the morning of the 24th of march
all staff were asked to work from home
wherever possible so
that was an instruction from the council
that that had to
happen and that applied to all staff who
um
undertook a role and that was um able to
be
um carried out at home obviously over
those initial few weeks
it was getting equipment and um the
actual practicalities of enabling people
to work at home
and but that was the instruction that
went out um
during that period um in terms of the
office roles
epsilon in terms of the roles that were
able to be undertaken from home
um obviously frontline roles um
contact centers some of the staff could
remain at home and there was a bit of a
road arrangement in place but
um it'd be street scene um obviously
leisure services
uh we ended up following those members
of staff
and because they weren't able to
undertake their work from home but many
of them were redeployed to the community
response team
um and um
it was largely those based in the
offices the
homework
okay thank you very much so we'll move
on to the
next item and then we will we've got to
consider the home policy
as well afterwards so thank you very
much for this update
very useful and very interesting
actually so
a lot of useful information can i
suggest as well
if any member uh feel that they have
other questions after this meeting that
have not so that
they've just not to ask right now
we can do that by email as well and i'm
sure we can have some
answers from sarah on various issues so
if you think of anything else you'd want
to know
perhaps contact sue directly
and then he can be fed to the committee
as well as part of our
assessment as well okay so we'll move on
to the next item thank you very much so
the scrutiny review
which is a page 8 and 50 for those who
are following it on their agenda online
and the first item is to approve the
project plan
and timetable for the review and
so sue uh would you like to run us
through that
yes thank you try to get to it yes okay
um the first part is the project plan
and that's
really sets out what you agreed at your
last meeting so it's just that
in a completed document so you can uh
see what you've asked
yeah uh to be scheduled in for the year
yeah and then the and so obviously if
there is anything that's missing off
there
if members just let us know then we can
amend that but i think it was pretty
comprehensive what you thought
yeah the last couple of meetings when
you discussed it yeah and then
there's a timetable and um i've
completed that a little bit since
um the last meeting uh you've probably
noticed uh rebecca
sitting in the meeting room with us
she's agreed to come along and talk
through the health and safety and events
and how her team
uh coped and then you've got an
interview from the director of
environmental
uh environmental enforcement which is
karen hanson yeah
and then you'll see on the next couple
of meetings there's those categories
that you identified
the people that you want to talk to and
i had a conversation with the chair i
think it was yesterday
chair where um i've actually now put
that
uh notice on the internet that you
requested inviting
staff to put the names forward to talk
to the council
um and you'll see see the categories
there and um
pretty flexible about that the idea is
we'll have little mini
uh discussion groups with groups of
staff yeah but obviously chair if some
if some staff members are a bit
reluctant i think as a mop up at the end
of that we'll also do some sort of
gathering in thoughts if people put a
submission in
yes with some people that um that feel a
bit nervous about perhaps attending
committee or
saying something probably and can i just
uh uh i'm trying to remember
going through it whether or not there
was uh indication to me
to the staff members that those
discussions would be
potentially via an online meeting rather
than
in person yes what we'll do is
do them in the normal uh meeting session
so it's the next two meetings on the
third of november and the second of
february
i think probably we will have to go into
confidential sessions so people can
speak freely
yeah because obviously we are um live
now and there may be some
uh things that obviously are
confidential those staff involved
yeah um but the idea is perhaps we'll
have half a dozen
people we'll see what response we get
but half a dozen people in a room
where members can have a question and
answer session
about you know the various things that
you've been writing so far
and staff are aware that that would be
via zoom
yeah in the notice i put out
good good good any questions on the
plan and the timetable
no okay
so i mean i have not seen anything that
was missing from the
project plan is quite uh for what we
what we're looking at
and hopefully when it comes to may 21
things may 21 will have a
report and recommendations to put
forward to the
cabinet as per usual yes councillor
birkin
thank you chair just a quickie um around
the aims and objectives regarding what
sarah has just said about some ad hoc
arrangements coming in
uh can we make sure that um one thing i
think we need to look at is to make sure
that the
policy is not only being effective but
it's being followed properly and fully
by all managers in all areas that
that speak to the equality issues that
are important about it
and i think as well on the on the key
issues we ought to be looking at as well
as potential benefits perhaps potential
problems
again including equality issues uh just
as we drill down a little bit deeper
into what's been going on
thanks a lot okay so
i'm happy for this to be included
actually the first
point uh aims and objectives i think
you're right in terms of the last
item we could potentially make sure that
after is effective we do add
and uh applied uh
properly by by the all departments or
something like that
i mean i i believe it would be covered
by the fact that it would be effective
because
police that's effective if the policy is
also
applied properly and that's how it is
effective
uh the key issues yes we could have a
look at the potential
uh issues with regard to working from
home
because as well and i think we discussed
it uh
i'm not too sure which forum it was but
i'm sure we mentioned last time that not
everybody
would be happy working from home
and some people who have been very happy
just at the beginning of lockdown to be
working from home and then
three months down the line decided well
that's not that's
as much fun as i thought it would be so
we've got to be mindful that we're not
uh we're looking at all the aspects and
i think that's why
from my perspective we're really keen to
speak to members of staff
and to have that their point of view so
that's a crucial point i think
um yep
anybody else on this item
yeah can i just add one final comment
really not the question
yeah i think where
the council has been through covid is
one set of circumstances
and that looks like that's going to
continue for quite a while now
probably six months maybe maybe even
longer
so the current operation is probably
where it's going to be for a while
going forward in the longer term i do
see this as
quite a radical change opportunity
it could be a great opportunity for
certain parts of the business
but it could also be a high risk for
people as well and for the business
so an individual preference is fine
and everyone will have their own
particular preference
but you are still running a service in a
business
so i think the management team are
pretty key
on how they think this is working can
they make this work
going forward if you do go towards a
radical change of
you could have 50 of people working from
home
so i think the management team should
certainly be part of the discussion
process
yeah definitely and that's what we will
be involving
the management team as well in that in
those
surveys as well can i just say as well
um
i completely agree with you i think that
the
crucial part for our assessment will be
the next four to five months
because now we're entering although
we're still under some sort of log down
and
having to work from home a lot more than
we might have wanted
but the initial
crisis if you like we've dealt with and
now we've got systems in place
to deal with all the lockdown issues
that have been uh so it's thought it's
all the things we've had to deal with
under very exceptional circumstances at
the beginning of lockdown
we've kind of resolved so it's my point
of view is that over the next five to
six months this probably
would give us a better picture on how
the council performance
service performance is actually doing in
terms of the
productivity in terms of how
managers are handling their staff
our flexible working is actually
working for the council so
i think that's probably going to give us
quite a lot of and like you said it's a
big opportunity for this council but
we've got to be aware of the risks as
well
in terms of the service that we need to
provide
yeah i agree with that
at least so we'll move on to the next
item unless there are
any other question on this item the next
item
is the homeworking policy so
um
yes to consider the working from home
policy
and associated documents uh so what i
would say
suggest is sarah are you
wanting to just give us a brief
introduction and always kind of touch
upon that
um yes i can do um
in terms of the home working policy
itself it is quite
um an old document that is uh
you know it is timely to review and
particularly with the developments in
technology and different ways of working
so
it is good that we're getting a lot of
feedback on that
um now in terms of how that can work and
as you've mentioned
um you know the changes to the workplace
that have happened over the last few
weeks would normally take years to
implement and put in place
so um you know feedback on on that home
working policy in
in consideration as to how best we could
um implement
homework arrangements moving forward
would be really beneficial
i know a lot more staff now like you
mentioned some
some were really against them working
but now they've had to try it they
actually see the benefits of that and
managers are getting more used to
managing staff in that situation as well
which was also
would have been in the past quite a big
barrier to overcome
um and now they've seen that it has
worked it has helped
and it's all the benefits of homework
and the flexibility to both the council
and the employee that it can it can um
introduced so yeah happy to receive any
comments or thoughts on it really
okay have we got any comments uh
one question before uh before we start
so we we're reviewing the
homeworking policy what uh
timetable are you putting yourselves
when do you expect to have a
revised draft first draft at least that
we could
consider um yeah
it's um obviously there's quite a few
people that need to be consulted as part
of this process so the normal steps that
um i have to go through with any new
policy
is that initially it would go to the
senior management team to review
so we're at the point where hopefully
within the next two to three weeks
a draft policy will be going forward to
the senior management team
and then that would commence
consultation with the um trade unions
so um i just need to check but yes i
would have thought at that point and we
also consult with the
managers um and employees will be
involved as part of that
process of feeding back through the
union so hopefully within the
next month to six weeks um there should
be a draft
and policy able to be reviewed
okay so so i'm just thinking we have a
meeting of the third of november i just
wonder if
we could have some sort of even if it's
just the
main headlines but at least we've got an
opportunity to see
where we're going with it and perhaps
input some of our
comments as well that's fantastic yeah
and that'd be quite useful and at least
we've got
uh a preview of what's uh what the
council and the
as an organization is um uh looking at
implementing that'd be great any
questions or comments
uh councilwork and i know you've asked a
question earlier do you have another
question
thank you chair um a few things yeah
i'll try to be quick with them uh
3.3 says one of the reasons for
temporary
working from home could be a backlog of
administrative tasks
um i would suggest that there may be
other areas that need to be looked at
vis-a-vis why the backlog built up uh
rather than just say no that's okay you
can go home and work on it quickly
i can see some issues there um
in item in a paragraph four four one
process can take up to 14 weeks to
complete that seems an extraordinary
long
length of time um you know a third of
the year a quarter of the year whatever
whatever
a quarter of the year um i appreciate
what sarah just said about these
lockdown as as a speed of things needs
most i think is the
um the uh the watchword but uh 14 weeks
it
seems an echo of a long process
time sorry for that to take um
the other thing they had was talking
about the responsibility of the person
at home and we seem to be putting a lot
of those onto them won't automatically
pay any costs
despite the fact that there may be uh
additional costs for heating lighting
um equipment if it's their own equipment
broadband that sort of stuff
they said the council would not usually
reimburse any increase in
uh insurance premium so my question
would be
would that be a reason for the
individual to be able to refuse
um an instruction to
uh to work from home uh and the next one
that was eight three the next one eight
four talks about employees liability
um which says it may ever be very
difficult to prove negligence on the
path to the council
because an officer working at home will
be primarily responsible
in his or her own working environment
um but i think somewhere earlier it says
that that would be checked out by uh i
think it's nearly even suggesting a line
manager visiting at home
so wouldn't we require health and safety
or um somebody like that to
check before an agreement is made and
that that would mitigate against the
individual being being held responsible
especially if we are requiring them to
be working from home
thank you chair okay
so quite quite a few comments here do
you want to
come back on some of those comments siri
yeah i cannot answer a couple of those
thank you
yeah the time scales for implementing
the homework in policy
i'm i'm not sure where the 14 weeks
comes from
it does seem overly long for me and i
know when we've
been dealing with individuals coming
back from sickness absence for example
and we're looking to put him working in
place we've turned that round in a week
and there are legislative requirements
in line with home working
in terms of the environment that they're
working in and i know and back you might
touch on this later on
um for insurance reasons as well
um there are steps that we need to make
sure the employee is aware
of um in terms of the
um utilities costs um there is
um provision under the tax office rules
that an employee can claim
um six pounds a week um for working from
home it is up to them to claim that
because obviously the council isn't
aware of any
you know the other activities that might
be um taking place within an
individual's home so the individual
themselves has to
um claim that i'm not it's not something
that the council can do
for them but we can um advise them that
that
is available for them to claim if they
wish to do so and some employees have
done that during this um
lockdown period and over recent weeks um
i'm just trying to think of the other
questions there
oh and costs as well obviously employees
are experiencing less costs because
they're not having to commute
anymore to work and so there is a saving
to the employee
on that front as well they may have to
undertake travel during the working day
if they
take site visits for example or have to
visit um
businesses like environmental health do
but in terms of traveling into the
office which would routinely
have been a normal practice for
employees if they are working from home
obviously they are not incurring
um that cost so that's something that is
one of the benefits the employees of
home working as well but yeah thank you
for those points i've noted them down
and they'll make sure that they are
considered as part of the
policy thank you
can i ask a couple more questions sarah
yeah of course yeah
i've not looked into working from home
seriously i think it's a good idea i
think it makes a lot of sense
but does your home awaken from home does
your
room become an extension of your
business office
so does it become an own office if you
like
and and if it does does that mean the
legislation
involved with working in an office
applies to your home
and i'm thinking things like pat testing
of equipment um
fire evacuation fight all those sort of
things that apply to
a works office did they transfer to your
home office
i'm not sure yeah there are there are
some subtle differences
because obviously you're talking about
the individual's own property rather
than
anything that belongs to the councils so
there is
more responsibility put on the employee
um in terms of working from their own
home
rather than working from a council
building and
in terms of the detail and all the
questions that you've just asked there
and the factors that you have raised
i'd have to look into those in full
detail because the rules have been
slightly relaxed over this recent period
of time
and but i know when that previous policy
and well the existing policy was put in
place
and there was quite a focus on insurance
and liability and where that
responsibility lied and it does seem to
fall more onto the employee than the
employer obviously both parties have a
duty of care so the employee has a duty
of care to ensure that
they're carrying out their work safely
and but as a council as well and as
their employer
we have a duty of care to them so we
have to make sure that we've put all the
steps
possible in place to support them while
working from home
i don't know if you have any more detail
on that becky
that you might want to add at this stage
in terms of homework
um but it's something that we need to
make sure is included in the guidance
with the new policies so that everybody
understands
the expectations on both sides um in
terms
in terms of homework you're right we've
got limited um influence over
how people choose to set out the homes
and how they operate we have put
together
um sort of a home working
self-assessment checklist that asks them
to consider
you know if they've got a fire escape of
the
have they had the wiring um tested um
make sure that they're not sort of slip
strips and falls and that they're
careful with cables and
and that kind of thing when they are at
home because obviously i mean
we physically haven't got the capacity
to go out and do
um however many dse assessment so we
couldn't possibly visit everybody's home
uh so we give them a home working
self-assessment checklist gives them
some things to think about within their
working environment
and things that they might maybe
wouldn't have considered
in the first instance and obviously
sarah's team have put out lots of
guidance on um so working routines and
and maintaining that so it is sort of an
extension of your workplace but we do
have
sort of limited influence the biggest
thing would be
for dsc assessments and currently
they've got
a homeworking presentation for dsd
and i know a lot of employees have taken
equipment from the office which is great
and but also sometimes even with that
equipment
you know they've not got a designated
office space so they're working from
maybe a coffee table or the dining table
so we've tried to put some suggestions
together
um on how they could utilize um what
they do have to best effect
but i think it would it would come down
to some decisions in the future on
whether or not they would have
an equipment allowance and whether they
could have guests or chairs but again it
is whether they've got the space and
they can cost
in their own home councillor birkin yeah
thank you chad just to show my stupidity
what is dse
um and i'd also have worries on the
council's behalf
um i appreciate what rebecca just said
about the potential volume of
of uh home workers and therefore checks
that need to be done
but if there was a problem sorry given
if there's a problem then i would
i would fear that the authority could be
liable because giving a checklist um
you're giving that to um
to if you like amateur health and safety
specialist health and safety
um work
is a a specific and important and
dedicated career rebecca self shows
and so to put all the training expertise
and qualifications that
such as rebecca has had on to uh
a noggin such as me i was working at
home for the first time
i think we could uh head for some
potential difficulties there i think we
need to
we would need to tighten up on that side
a bit but what what is dlc sorry
yeah sorry you you get um tied up in
your own little acronyms i do apologize
so dsc is display screen equipment
basically
to your keyboard and your laptop and so
thank you
and we do offer sort of quite a bit of
guidance we've given them a checklist
we've also got a fact sheet on how to
set up
your display screen equipment as i say
we've done a presentation
showing how they can make best use of
the home equipment
um there's a dse form which again i know
it's self-assessment and possibly not
ideal
but it sort of highlights um any issues
in the first instance that they would
raise with the service management
might be as simple then as just you know
asking if they can have a new chair
um if they can have a laptop riser and
they're all quite simple
if there was anything significant and
you know people weren't able to get
comfortable
um in their own environment then of
course we could facilitate visits or
do it for every employee um
you know thinking about frontline and
who we've got at home we've got about
200 home workers or something
but i have you know having to drive
between each location and
there's two of us um it would take a
significant amount of time but if there
was any
particular issues then yeah of course we
could make that um that arrangement
yeah it is important to uh to to
understand that
there is a degree of responsibility that
is on the staff
in the same way as people working in an
office
you do have to apply the health and
safety guidance that are given to you by
the
organization but if a staff member is
putting themselves
at rest by not following the guidance
even within the organization and inside
the building
there's still some sort of
responsibility that falls onto the the
staff so
completely understand that point so i've
got councillor leget on
all i that going to ask is if you've
taken home council equipment
if you have a break-in or
um your the equipment gets damaged
are you covered by the council's
insurance or your own home insurance
um i honestly don't know the answer to
that one um i suppose it depends on the
level
i've of have you any uh thoughts on that
one sorry you got any idea um
no i think it needs to come under um
the employees insurance as well because
they need to
you know if you're taking out buildings
insurance and contents insurance you
need to make clear what
you know is or isn't covered within that
and the actual breaking will have
occurred
in an individual's home we have had
situations before where
um laptops have been taken from cars um
and that has resulted in um
some form of not not full on
disciplinary but we have
raised that with the individuals to make
sure they are following the guidance and
we don't expect
things like laptops to be um left on the
back seat of cars for
um as a target for thieves so there are
um some expectations in terms of how
individuals will care for the equipment
but
i think it comes under the individual's
own insurance but obviously
the council will have some cover the
actual equipment itself but in terms of
it
being taken from the individual's
premises i think it falls under their
insurance part of
what we'd have to look at and with their
home working policy
okay thank you very much yeah councillor
potts
yep yeah it's just a very quick one on
data protection and security
and i would imagine that this will be
almost impossible to police
in in the um working at home
you know in terms of keeping documents
secure leaving them lying around the
house
people possibly overhearing confidential
conversations
um how is that going to be managed
and we have put in place some steps so
far so
areas where we um know that could
potentially be a concern such as
revenues and benefits
um the staff have received um training
and guidance on what expectations are
there so if they do have any papers or
things at home they are to lock them
away
and if they are conducting telephone
conversations with them
residents or any other customers and
then you
need to make sure they are in a room
where no one else can overhear that they
take care
not to have their screen on open display
and like you would in the office you
lock your computer if you move away for
it to take
a quick break or anything and and follow
the standard guidance with that you're
right
we can't go and see within every
everybody's home
exactly and how they are managing that
but we have made it clear to employees
what the expectations are
um as as you would expect in the office
we expect people to
try and maintain those same protocols
within the home office environment
excuse me so yeah
thank you very much i think we'll move
on to the next
item if that's okay but thank you very
much and we're looking forward to seeing
that first draft
uh i think there's quite a lot of uh
comments have been put forward by
members
really useful from uh from my point of
view so
i'm sure some of us comments will be
included in the feedback
thank you very much so the next item
so it's a selection of built-ins so they
were included with the
with the documents and
sue could you just run us through
drafting of questions could you just
uh remind me what this uh
this is about the drafting of questions
for the interviews or for the staff
survey that we're
implying i couldn't remember what we
decided
it's just um it could be both actually
but obviously
rebecca's going to have a discussion
with you later yeah
but then we're going to go into these uh
mini groups so it's whether you want to
put any questions together in those
groups so you're asking the same things
to the groups
or which is what we normally do then you
can triangulate between
them um or whether you're going to have
a more
fluid thing where you just ask questions
on on the day
it's really for the committee to decide
chair what you think is most appropriate
okay so rebecca do you want to come in
on on the bulletin as well just to give
us a quick
overview of what was included in the
pack
and it's about the health and safety
bulletins is that the ones you you mean
sue no i think i think the the bulletins
chair i think
i think they came out from sarah's team
did this zara
right okay yeah because it was quite a
long uh
quite a few all the built-ins that you
put forward to staff throughout the
lockdown page this was quite quite
impressive so
that was really good so do we want to
just make comments on those or ask any
question to sarah there in this case
uh councillor liggy
uh so i was talking about
the um employees employees
uh well-being updates yeah yeah yes
yeah because our employees at the
eckington depot who don't get the extra
net
were supposed to have seen them um they
were put up on the notice boards
um and circulated him is my
understanding by the managers so anytime
we send anything out to service managers
or anything is placed on the
extranet and the managers and
office-based staff there make sure he
gets put up on the notice boards
at the depots boaster eckington and at
jolie west of the northeast staff work
out of as well
right do you have you any any ability to
go and check whether that was actually
done because
my husband said he'd never seen any of
them before
okay yeah i cannot ask the question uh
and just um
check what what term provisions were put
in place by the managers at those sites
so yeah that's no problem i'll check
that
out thank you that'd be useful yet thank
you very much
any other questions on the buildings
yeah just one more question about the
well-being update
the last one i've got sir is the 9th of
july
have you printed any more since then
uh now we provided two every week
um from march through to the end of um
july uh and that we haven't done any
since now and because what we have done
is we've done
as um rebecca mentioned we've contacted
every member of staff regarding their
dse set up so we've been focusing on the
home workers because we were conscious
that
the home working arrangements were going
to go beyond a few weeks into
potentially months
um so we've been asking managers to
focus on dealing with any
issues or and concerns that staff have
risen and phrased during that process um
and then i'm happy to take on you know
if people feel that those bulletins were
helpful we can reinstigate them again
obviously probably on a bi-weekly basis
rather than twice weeks it's quite a lot
of information to digest for the people
yeah i thought twice weekly was pretty
ambitious yeah
to go from twice weekly up through to
july and then suddenly stop
i just wondered why did you stop doing
it
uh well we also um it was something that
we were asked to do by council athacker
um it was initiated as well from him in
terms of the twice weekly bulletins
um but as the first of all well
at that point we thought staff would be
moving back and coming back into the
office environment
on a more regular basis and obviously
that hasn't transpired in practices
we're now experiencing the second wave
um so we had started prior to lockdown
having a quarterly health and wellbeing
bulletin
and we'd only got the first one of those
hours about six pages
just with all the events and things that
we've planned during this year because
there's a lot of things that haven't
happened as a result we would have had
the northeast summer social event out in
the quad
uh we would have had our normal
macmillan coffee morning taking place
um and we would have focused on every
month particular health and well-being
um themes and but because of the recent
events that that hasn't transpired but
it is something that
we need to look at now and see what we
can put in place moving forward based on
the new environment that we're working
in
yeah okay i think during lockdown the
the twice weekly
probably was required because of the
anxiety
uh from from all sorts of managers staff
counsellors nobody knew what what was
going to happen
or how we were supposed to to uh
deal with some of the issues that we
were put to put in front
so i think price weekly probably was
required but as we're progressing and
people
are getting used to the new normal and
i'm not sure every quarter
i would prefer something a bit more
regular every three months every two
months but
obviously you will have an idea of when
people actually pick
things up from my experience if you get
emails constantly
you end up ignoring them because these
health and well-being
are built and and it's no offense to
anybody but they are quite repetitive
and they have to be repetitive because
that's the nature of the business
we you know that there's we can't invent
issues
all the time so they're quite
competitive and i found that
if people are getting emails constantly
they end up ignoring them so to have
more impact sometimes it's better to
have one good email
every saucer and rather than loads of
emails that people aren't going to try
to put ignoring
councillor birkin
thank you chair yeah i firstly to say um
i thought those those briefings the
updates looked very good very effective
uh very efficient and uh and lots of
good general information
there i could learn with reading a few
of those myself uh maybe a few months
ago
um i agree with you you can be flooded
with
with emails uh it's it's a bind i think
i
found it particularly difficult but i
think again um
despite that it is worth reminding
people uh
about what's what's around here we we're
tending to forget it
uh this is most probably why we're going
into a second wave because we've all
forgotten about
washing our hands or two meters apart or
uh don't touch your face and all those
those simple little things
um so i agree uh i think this should be
a a regular thing maybe
once a month ish three weeks something
like that um
because i think it's a very it looks
like a very good service i would have
appreciated that
if i was working with the council at
this point in time so well done sarah on
that one
do we have any other comments or
questions on those bulletins
no uh councillor jones
yeah i'm just um what i was thinking is
that
a lot of people when they be isolated
like this
they miss out on the camaraderie in the
office
and information from other people
and i think that's quite important for
them so perhaps we could look at
ways of getting people that are
working to actually communicate with
each other
on an informal basis but just to keep
that going
so they don't feel isolated completely
and still feel part of the team
because that's quite important really um
so i was just one of the things i was
thinking about because
you know the things that normally went
on people go for a walk
in the lunch hour and things like that
so they actually met and talked and it
was a social side to
it so if we can work out ways to kind of
keep them links going
that's just the comments want to make
thank you so these comments could be
passed on as part of the homeworking
policy and
how we carry on with supporting our
staff in terms of health and well-being
right okay so we move on to the next
item because we're quite behind our
schedule
uh sue uh so could you just uh remind
members so the
the questions you you mentioned on the
agenda the questions
uh preparing questions so i just
wondered if members had any questions
specifically that they wanted to
have answered
if i could say chair um rebecca's going
to do
more a question and answer discussion
session because obviously it's health
and safety and that's played a key role
yeah and the questions um i was
particularly thinking about was when we
came to
um the mini discussion sessions with
staff perhaps to save time if it's all
right chair
would you be happy if members just um
sent question potential questions
to me yeah and i'll liaise with you to
get a final draft which we can ask
those discussion sessions i would
suggest that that probably would be the
best
way forward so if members could just
have a thing about some of the questions
they want
to ask the staff when we uh when we meet
them
or uh in terms of how
they were looked after or what they
found
quite helpful not helpful and
just so that it can feed our assessments
moving forward
uh with homework so if you could send
those
emails and copy everybody all members
and send them to sue
copy myself the chair and all members so
we don't repeat each
other's questions so it might be more
effective that way
and we'll put a list of questions ready
for for the next session
thank you that's fantastic yeah thank
you
so we'll move on to the next item on the
agenda
uh which is moving on to interviews so
members will remember we we agreed a
number
of interviews that we would like to um
to uh proceed with so
the first interview is rebecca attension
who is a health and safety coordinator
and so rebecca welcome and apologies
you've had to
wait a little bit
so would you like to give us first of
all
a quick presentation about um
your overall duties especially obviously
we're quite keen to hear about
the lockdown issues uh but i've after
that first
shall we uh introduce ourselves because
rebecca we've not met you before in this
forum uh so i'm angelique foster i'm a
counselor for drumfield
and the chair of
good morning rebecca hi i'm councillor
joe burkin councillor for sutton
conductment in ward
the posher area
council of pots
um i'm mo parts and i'm a member for
killer marsh west
morton
good morning rebecca my name's heather
liggett and i'm district councillor for
sherlin
stone broom brackenfield westington
yeah i'm maggie jones and i'm counsellor
for
clay cross south which includes james
moore
and councillor right
yes good morning my uh i'm councillor
um district councillor for john
dromfield
north okay i think that's all the
counselors
uh okay so rebecca over to you
okay thank you um so i'm rebecca i'm
health and safety coordinator joint
officer with um
northeastern bolsover i am in the
position of understudy for bronwyn
macarthur williams today so
hopefully i'll be able to answer
everything that you that you that you
want to know um
so is it do you just want me to
go through what we've done during the
lockdown period is that yeah if you
if you want to just give us a quick
overview and then we'll uh
we'll ask you some questions if that's
okay
okay yeah of course yeah that'd be great
um well i mean like like us all
a lot for all of us it's been it's been
particularly challenging
and i know sarah mentioned earlier that
so trying to keep up with the
guidance and then translate that into
our for our teams that are out there
working
was particularly challenging you you
seem to get a guidance note together
and off it went and then two days later
you needed to change it
again but that's just you know an
evolving situation so it's been
it's been quite um been quite a dynamic
sort of situation but
you know i'm sure we're all aware of
that and we've put out several uh pieces
of guidance one of the
the largest would be the kobe 19
protective measures guidance note and
that's currently its fourth issue and
it's due for another review
um by the end of um tomorrow which we've
done if it needs it just needs
sending out um so that sort of details
you know the the measures that
um key workers that they were initially
then they went to frontline workers and
then just generally
um you know people that are out there
meeting customers the measures that they
would need to take to keep
themselves safe and it was all a little
bit intense to be perfectly truthful
in the first instance but um has become
as we've moved towards this new normal
become relatively simple in terms of
you know the need to keep the distance
and that's your initially that's the
main control measure
and ensuring that they're washing the
hands frequently and
correctly and then and when they can't
do that then we can then put in the
mitigation of wearing face coverings and
the different types of working the
cohort work in
using screens side by side that kind of
thing
uh so that's sort of the overarching um
one
um and i think that formed a basis um
when it initially came out for david
broom's protocol
for the mill lane building and he took
responsibility
and ownership um for that and developed
that
so the risk assessment side of things is
looked after from the ground
um by david um
we've done quite a lot on um sort of
home working as i say we've got the
self-assessment checklist
we initially put out some health and
safety tips for working at home
sort of very um brief bullet points
which we've
we expanded on over time and that
initial um
health and safety tips is due to be
withdrawn because it's no longer
relevant we've got the dse
presentation uh for homework in so that
people can
um see some scenarios um and relate them
hopefully to their home
their home situation and i have to say
we've ruthlessly exploited our poor
apprentice for that because she's in all
of the photographs demonstrating
everything but
i think she was alright with it really
um
we've also um been trying to
ensure that we've got the covered um
secure standard
and all of our buildings so we've been
doing code secure um inspections
so just sort of spot effects again to
make sure that distance and markers are
in place
that people are wiping down frequently
contacted points
that we can observe people social
distancing that hand site eyes and
disinfectant paper towel that kind of
thing
is all available um we've worked quite
closely with um leisure teams
um so obviously the leisure centers were
were closed
um initially and then sort of opened up
mid to july
we went quite extensively um with those
uh
teams visiting each site um as they were
developing the pro
procedures because it got fourth of july
and then we got to delayed a bit so
everything was changing again all the
time
and then we did pre opening checks and
inspections for them
and being back since you know make sure
that they were
okay and um
they knew so what they wanted and
basically we responded um as requested
when you know to service managers if
they've needed us
to we've been generally working at home
if they've needed us to visit and
um been able to contact us via email
obviously phones
and we've also got a zoom uh so we've
gone
uh wherever we've been requested
um participating as well in the home
working group because
obviously that's gonna be a big
moving forward as well as you know the
bigger adaptations that we've had to
have
um now and possibly some challenges with
that as we said
briefly would be the provision of
equipment whether you know people have
got the space
um at home um and whether we give them
an allowance or manage it in some other
way
um i think that's everything i've got if
you if
there's anything else you need to know
please let me know
do we have any questions for rebecca
thank you
i think a lot because a lot of the the
aspects has been
we've discussed as we went along didn't
we so it's quite useful information
but it just shows how everything links
into each
everything links together anyway in
terms of health and well-being
specifically
any other questions from members we did
discuss about
the health and well-being of the staff
working
at home and how that's the implication
of
who's responsible for applying this and
and as i said before my view is that
there's a level of responsibility that
has to be put on the stack to make sure
that they actually
get the one thing that and i can't
remember so you have to
forgive me if that was done because
there was so much again there was so
much
information coming through and for for
us
who are dual hatches or triple hatches
uh like me there was so many so many
different information coming through
from different councils
but i didn't see a lot of things um
coming through from
this organization for advice to
counsellors about homeworking
and the workstations and the reason i'm
saying that it's very early on i
ended up with a very bad neck because
i've forgotten
you know about using the the
and because we were spending so much
time on the ipad looking down
i ended up with a very bad neck until i
realized okay
so i ended up buying myself something
where i could have which i'm using now
uh the the screen actually facing me and
high up
so i'm actually facing the screen now
but i just wanted
in terms of counsellors who are not used
to work in an office environment most of
us
uh because we're always out and about
and suddenly we found ourselves working
a lot uh at home on equipment
that we might have just picked up every
now and then usually
and there wasn't a lot of i don't know
what your impressions is
as counselors but i didn't feel there
was a lot of kind of remember
reminders or advice so correct me if i'm
wrong
uh i might have missed them uh going
through it but
i see a few of the counselors nodding
we're doing need looking after as well
yeah i think that i think that's a fair
point um yeah
i suspect that's got uh sort of missing
and we were definitely focused on
employees everything went down to
service managers but yeah obviously you
guys wouldn't get that information so
um i mean would you would that kind of
information be useful like um we can
make sure that we get actually i
think it will yeah i think moving
forward obviously
i've kind of read up on things and
realized that
you know it's probably not a good thing
to kind of look down to your ipad
constantly
so i kind of work things out a little
bit but
obviously uh not everybody would have uh
will have the
access to information like that or be
used to look for the information it'd be
useful to us some
some health and well-being advice
central councillors as well
yeah yeah councillor just to endorse
that council foster i would agree and
that is one of the points that i've got
written down that i wanted to bring up
but this is very much
uh this should very much involve
councils as well because we weren't used
to working from home and
you know like you i've had the same
problem and this is my ipad stand
um you know and i would find it very
useful if we were
included on these um on these bulletins
yeah definitely
yeah okay and what i'll do is i'll i'll
take back to our
team then we'll we'll put together all
the information um
that we've we've shared with employees
as a bit of a pack
and just making sure it's shared with
all of you if that's okay
yeah councillor berkin you wanted to ask
a question oh no
right okay anybody else yeah councilor
jones
yeah i mentioned it last time about
my granddaughter is actually working for
an examining board at the time
and she was having to work from home in
isolation
and she was getting a lot of flack of
people ringing up because it wasn't
going through you know what's going to
happen about the exams and all that
and she found that very difficult and
it's about
us dealing with people who are angry
and staff as well having to put up with
this
in their own home and she found that
very very difficult
so i just wondered if there's anything
we could give people so they feel that
they've got some back up on that
i'd ask sarah if she's available to come
in on this and then we've got the
um the be supported um helpline and
for me i think that would be the sort of
go-to
um for people if they were struggling
and experiencing difficulty while they
were
at home yeah i'd agree we do
have um an employee assistance program
which quite a few organizations do now
and i know many other local authorities
that didn't have one to begin with um
have
signed up to one during the course of
this lockdown which provides 24-hour
and seven-day a week um services on a
range of issues
and that employees and their family
members can access
and we have had quite a few
conversations with managers about those
struggling and to work at home and
struggling with the
self-isolation and we are looking at
mental health
and and working on um what initiatives
we can put in place now given the new
environment and the new normal that we
are working in
where things like this are coming more
to the fore and so
as mentioned previously i think there is
a lot of information out there regarding
well-being and it's just making sure
that you put that into our
easy to understand and digestible format
for individuals and that is relevant to
them as well
and making sure you're given the right
advice because there's lots of theories
and ideas out there
and it's about what works for you as an
individual as well
um you know there isn't a right or a
wrong answer for everybody it's just
making sure that
the things that we have got in place um
you know do work
for everybody but a range of options are
offered
councillor berkin did you have your hand
up for no
okay any other questions
i have one more question but if any
member i've got
a question first okay so and
my question rebecca then so we've kind
of uh
discussed all the health and well-being
issues ability that they're going
through
i've just wondered from your point of
view moving forward because obviously
we're
going to work on this uh working from
home policy reviewing it
do you have any comments or that you
already
feel that moving forward will need to be
implemented will
need to be part of that home working
policy in terms of the
from your perspective during lockdown
nothing nothing in particular at the
moment i mean i know this
we're part of the home working group
and that's looking at this issue
corporately and i know quite a few
things have been sort of brought to the
table there i think um
you know it's being considered as a as a
holistic issue so we're looking at
it from all angles i think you know from
the benefits possibly in the
and the drawbacks as well but i don't
think there's anything
at this point that hasn't been
considered in
in terms of working from home sort of
long term
um but i think it's quite clear that
there are no easy answers
um and sometimes when you answer one
query
you find that you you've given yourself
another one but
you know that's the that's the the great
thing about you having
a variety of offices on this group so
we're also looking at it from different
perspectives yeah
okay and are you satisfied from this
perspective from another council i know
that the survey that's come back from uh
after locked down well uh still
in some sort of look down but during the
summer survey was done
to staff we were working on the lockdown
and in terms of their mental health
uh and it came back quite positive
in terms of how staff had coped with the
mental health of the worst
felt supported by the council so i'm
talking about a completely different
organization
have you had any feedback in terms of
talking about the physical side with the
back and things but in terms of mental
health which is quite
an important issue now yeah to be fair
um
the mental health aspect that really
sits with them sorrows teams it's a bit
more of a confidential issue with more
you know broken backs and that kind of
thing so yeah
okay so you don't share that
responsibility sarah then
well that's fine i'll give you an
overview
um of where we are with that we have and
that was one of the reasons behind the
health and well-being bulletins as well
and it has come more to the fore in
terms of mental health and well-being
um during recent weeks and as part of um
the practices that we've encouraged
managers to do is have that regular
contact with
their team um both in team meeting set
up so you are getting that engagement
with other colleagues
but also on a one-to-one basis as well
so reminders were sent out to managers
to make sure they having as a minimum
weekly contact with individuals
depending on how big their team was and
but often it would be daily contact
both from making sure that um you know
work activities are being undertaken and
services we're performing
but also just to check in and have that
chat with individuals
from working in in the office and
throughout the period
um often i did find employees did come
in just to say hello i went to chat
because there were so few people in the
building they did
enjoy coming in and seeing somebody face
to face if they to print some
um information out and and sometimes you
know when you were dealing with queries
you would have a longer conversation
with somebody because they were working
at home and you just said it was nice to
have a chat with you i've not
spoken to you for a while or seen you
for a while so it is
it is something that you know the
council will have to look at and along
the term
basis to put those steps in place and as
becky says we've
focused a lot on the physical but also
on the mental side of it as well but
that is an ever-growing
um area of work with different research
and theories coming in all the time
so that is going to be you know
really something interesting to get our
teeth into moving forward as well
because it is going to be so diverse and
and dynamic moving forward and um you
know
it's it's making sure we get that that
right support out there
and for individuals and taking into
account each individual circumstance as
well
okay yeah thank you so any other
questions
no so thank you very much rebecca you're
welcome to stay
if you want but at the same time equally
we know that you you might be a very
busy person so
happy if you if you feel that you you
need to pop out
yeah i will thank you thank you for
having me and uh
been nice to meet you all yeah thank you
for your time thank you and we'll see
you soon
bye-bye
and we have the next item we which is a
presentation
from uh karen hansen and i see that
karen has just joined us with questions
and answers karen is the director of
environment and
enforcement
welcome karen thank you morning that was
really good timing wasn't it
excellent thank you i'm just going to
see if i can share my screen
so i don't know who's sue are you
hosting the
session
no um there's there's a number of people
we've got amy brandt who's just
just on screen so i think she'll just
made you co-host so you should be able
to thank you very much
thank you okay let's get started
okay can everybody see what's on the
screen can everyone see the presentation
okay um let me just move that out of the
way right okay so thank you
um for inviting me along i know that uh
you're gonna be doing i'm not sure what
you've already discussed this morning so
i really hope
that i don't duplicate what's already
been said but
what i thought i would do um and i can
come back at a later date if you if you
want me to look at
anything more specific but what i wanted
to do this morning was to
um set the scene really in terms of what
happened from the 23rd of march onwards
in
the council how we managed um
from that moment onwards to make sure
that we had
the resources in place a business
continuity arrangements and kind of
setting the scene
uh for for what we're doing over the
next six months so i'm just gonna
talk you through that and then i'll be
able to answer any specific questions
um and i know that sarah will have a lot
more information than me in terms of
detailed
um documents and procedures that have
been out to staff etc so i'm just gonna
do a little bit of scene setting if
that's okay
so on the 23rd of march you'll be aware
that the prime minister
um announced to everybody on the
national
uh television about the lockdown
measures that were going to be taking
place so
i am the emergency planning lead for the
council and the business continuity lead
in terms of the civil contingencies act
and we are required to make sure we have
um arrangements in place and that we're
prepared for any emergency
arrangements or emergencies that may
occur so um
what i did on that night was speak to
both of the leaders at bowls over in
northeast derbyshire
in terms of what we were going to be
putting in place immediately to protect
the staff
um from the the arrangements that
nationally were required to put in place
that night
so at half past nine on that evening
i've sent an email out to all
of the heads of service and i just want
to give you a flavor of that i trawled
through
my emails last night and managed to find
it
so basically we asked all staff to stay
at home from that point onwards
except those who were registered as
priority one services so things like
waste collection
um all of those kinds of um business
continuity arrangements
um services that were required to carry
on as normal
but we said that we would speak to all
the heads of service in the morning the
next day
um if staff were unable to work due to
lack of equipment we would uh
deal with that urgently and could they
make best endeavors to ensure that all
staff are aware of the updates
that they didn't come into work and um
and that we were able to put in place
the measures that we needed to do
to comply with the new guidance that
came out that evening
okay so what did we do from the next
morning onwards we
uh did an urgent visual check of the
mill lane office to make sure that all
staff have got the message
we sent some home uh we spoke to others
we've discussed um
which services needed to continue from
the office and which could be done from
home
we then had some very early discussions
i remember driving into work on that
morning speaking to steve brunt about
the street scene services
because we have a statutory duty to
collect
waste as you know as you'll be aware um
we've also had grounds maintenance
staff which isn't statutory duty and
other um
things like mot testing and parts of the
depot which are
available to the public so we had to
have some urgent discussions around
which parts of that service we would
continue um
that day we then set up an emergency
control center so for those of you who
are not aware i
then um sat in the members room for the
next
three months every day with matt
broughton
basically controlling uh what was
happening
across the whole of the council in terms
of service provision
working very closely with the leader
with cabinet and members
with the comms team and with partners
uh to make sure that we were able to
continue and to look after vulnerable
people as well
business continuity plans were initiated
and um
myself and lee hicken met with the
leaders to agree how we would split
ourselves between the two councils so
we agreed that as a one-off measure lee
hicken would go to bowls over and i
would work in the middle lane office
permanently so we weren't wasting
time driving from one building to the
other and kind of
trying to cover both councils between us
so i
concentrated exclusively on north east
derbyshire
we arranged for letters of authorization
so that all key workers were able to
travel freely if they got stopped by the
police
um we asked all managers to contact
staff that day
and then ict set about their massive
task of ensuring that homeworking
would be able to go ahead uh that we had
hardware software security arrangements
telephony in place
and that went on for some time
okay so we also sent out daily emails
you'll be aware of those from the leader
to all staff and all members to make
them feel engaged with
what we were doing so people didn't feel
left out in the cold and that they
weren't
um concerned about arrangements that
were in place and we tried to make it as
accessible as possible so that people
could ask questions of anybody whether
it be the leader myself
hr their own service managers
we issued and sarah um very quickly
went uh into action to issue workplace
measures so we've got a temporary
workplace
procedure document agreed by the trade
unions by the 26th of march
we've refreshed it three times since
then and we're now looking at a further
one
um at the kind of uh phase two of the
or wave two of the coronavirus measures
that we're now looking at but um
we've made some very clear arrangements
for staff which
i'm sure sarah will go through with you
in more detail as part of your
program we we considered all government
advice you can imagine it was coming out
hourly to start with across a huge range
of service areas everything from the
provision of funerals
to events to training to
environmental health offices
requirements regulations
um all sorts of uh government advice and
guidance were coming out on a very
regular basis
um we're engaged with trade unions
uh and we also got to work immediately
in terms of procurement
of ppe which is protective equipment so
things like
gloves the face masks all of the hand
sanitizers
we wanted to make sure the staff had
everything available to them whether
they were working from home or working
out
on the patch so to speak okay
the local resilience forum which you may
be aware of
it's the lrf every area across
the country is required to have a local
resilience forum so every
emergency that you'll be aware of that
happens things like
big flooding events um the dam
issue that we had last year all of those
types of events will be managed by a
local resilience forum
and their partners around the table that
can um
they can state that we're having an
emergency event
they can put in place loads of
arrangements call on
lots of funding to ensure that
residents and businesses and life
itself is protected as much as possible
those gold meetings which are called the
strategic coordinating group scg
for covid have been ongoing since that
first
day so they were initially daily seven
days a week
which i dialed into they then moved to
uh
three times a week and then uh weekly
and then they got to fortnightly um
until they started to ramp up again
so now with the um the second wave of
the virus we're now back to weekly
monday morning meetings across that
strategic group
we're also um as a council we also
um are part of the tactical group and
the subgroup so
there's subgroups set up around things
like recovery
around cohesion and enforcement issues
policing
all sorts of different subgroups looking
at communications and
and to make sure that we're coordinated
across the whole of the county
and initially as well to start with we
had regular samps meetings so the
strategic alliance management team
which is made up of the directors and
the heads of service met
every day to make sure we're aligning
our message for staff
and that we were all working together
picking up good ideas from each other
so um over the next four months april
may june and july we set
up the campaign my apologies but uh
um i know you're sharing your screen but
it's not flicking through
so yeah
are you one the one that says april to
july
no oh so i don't know what it's like for
all the members
amy can you do it if i stop it can you
share it
yeah that's fine
i'll stop mine
i'll send this out to make sure that
you've got it because we're all we're
halfway through yeah
it didn't really that'd be useful thank
you yeah so it's on my ice cream but
it's not flicking through i thought it
was a long introduction
that's what i thought and then you
mentioned about uh dates again and i
thought well
i must have missed the last one then
that's better
thank you yeah we've missed the first
four
slides sorry it's flicking through on my
screen but clearly not uh
working through to yours so sorry about
that i'll just make sure it's sent out
with the notes
okay so april to july we set up the
community support team
um and we had a large number or
a number of staff who were unable to
work from home for various reasons
because it wasn't the kind of job that
you could do from home for instance we
had
leisure staff particularly uh where we
closed the leisure centers
who volunteered and it was a really good
piece of work
um in terms of everybody kind of hands
the pump
getting things done for the benefit of
our communities so
we set up a community support team we
had members of the contact center
phoning
vulnerable uh uh residents um
for weeks on end to make sure that they
were okay
we seconded staff into the roles
we looked at the shielding arrangements
and worked with derbyshire county
council to get
food boxes out to people we made
telephone contact with vulnerable
residents and
did food deliveries medicine deliveries
working very closely with ricknall homes
we set up food collection points at the
food banks and we also tried to assist
with mental health
arrangements with jigsaws games
magazines we sent out
copies of the derbyshire times to the
most isolated i think there were about
30 people
that were so isolated and were feeling
so terrible at that point that we
we tried to engage them with some local
news and telephone them daily
and so the group of staff that did that
were
really really engaged with that i think
they enjoyed it and
really made the best that we could with
those particular individuals who weren't
able to work
from home okay amy can you move that
forward
okay is that changed for you
yeah okay so we also um
regularly reviewed the arrangements both
for homeworking and for
mill lane we've got a risk assessment
set up for all service managers to risk
assess what's happening
on the ground we set up the sanitizing
stations with all of the hand sanitizer
and we did a big piece of work which
took a few days really to
count the number of desks in the in the
offices
we looked at the two meter rule how many
people we could get per
area marked those spaces out
you'll have seen lots of two meter
stickers all over the buildings
um to make sure that the staff were
working safely in accordance with the
the rules
we also looked at other places so what
kingdom depot coney green
all of the council's business premises
as well
and for street scene in particular we
reviewed all of the plans we put
back a phased return of some of the
services you'll be aware
that we took green waste out for a few
weeks so that we could concentrate on
safe
working arrangements for the residual
waste collections
but eventually we brought all of that
back in place with a safe or working
arrangement
um where we possibly could
and then sarah's team has done a really
good job as well to
weekly monitor self-isolation
staff sickness levels weekly returns on
how many staff we've got working
and whether staff are doing everything
they could to work from home
thanks amy okay
so we've also undertaken a home working
survey so we asked
people what they thought about working
from home by this point we were kind of
a maybe may time it became
quite obvious to us that some staff
luckily luckily not a huge number but
some staff were struggling a little bit
more with homeworking than others
particularly single people who felt
quite isolated and
lonely we had maybe two or three where
we had to
really uh contact them regularly to make
sure
that their mental health was um was
being looked after and that they felt
supported by
by the council within with their work
and we did everything we possibly could
for them and we continue to continue to
do that
um we've done a work station
assessment to make sure that people
aren't working on the laps on the sofas
um that where possible we've got
equipment
in place we still have some work to do
on that we've had those questionnaires
back and we're still working our way
through them
but i'm hopeful and i think sarah might
be able to help with this one but i'm
hopeful the staff are aware that they
can
come to us and request additional
equipment if they need it
or if they've got any issues with their
workstation
that they're aware that they can bring
that up with the managers and we'll do
everything we can
for that
we made constant contact around mental
health issues which i've just mentioned
we're also very conscious that
some staff had child care
responsibilities and we had to put in
place flexible working arrangements
those staff didn't particularly want to
take annual leave they were happy to
work from home
but we had to be very flexible in what
they could do
and how they could do it and we allowed
working up to around 11 o'clock at night
for some individuals if they needed to
start later and finish later
to get the work done but also to
support their families and especially
families that are in isolation
um to get services back to the new
normal um
and also just to mention there that
we've also taken on a lot of additional
responsibilities in environmental health
so
uh all of the new covid acts copied
regulations
around enforcement um particularly in
business premises and
restaurants we've had to do a lot of
extra work for that so people
um have been very very busy in that team
okay thanks amy
okay just to carry on um with what we've
done we've provided a lot of advice to
staff who were shielding
or vulnerable part of that vulnerable
group and some people
had families that they were very
concerned about so just to give you a
couple of examples
somebody in our street scene service had
a child that was born very prematurely
uh is now
not a baby anymore but still has issues
in terms of
breathing and other kind of respiratory
problems and was very concerned about
coming into work so
we did a lot of risk assessments for
individuals taking into account their
family circumstances to make the best
use we could have staff but to take into
account
what they also needed to do you'll be
aware we bought in furlough arrangements
for some staff in leisure particularly
and we also sent out a twice weekly
health and wellbeing bulletin
um for 12 weeks it was a big piece of
work that sarah's team did with that
we set up a toolkit for managers to put
all of this information into one place
so that they could find it easily
and we spent updates on a regular basis
to ensure
everybody was engaged um and then
finally extranet articles you'll be
aware
that we tried to do as much
communication as we could with staff
with members
all sorts of people to make sure that
they're aware of what was going on
okay what's next i think is the next
slide
yeah so this is what we're doing now
just to give you a quick update i'm near
the end
so uh we're continuing continuing to
regularly review working from home
arrangements
uh we make regular contact with staff
and we're continuing to make sure that
the office is uh covered secure
and that's become business as normal to
be honest all three of those areas now
are part and parcel of
everyday work everyday life we're
working with sarah and with other
managers
on the home policy working from home
refresh
and we're also looking at the second
wave arrangements because we're very
conscious that
the winter may bring us
a bit of a multiple uh issue situation
so we could be looking at
for instance heavy snowfall with covid
perhaps flu as well and we're still
working our way through the brexit
transition
and the change in regulation so we've
got quite a lot of
emergency type of issues business
continuity issues that we need
to stack up and make sure that we've got
everybody
in the right place doing the right thing
to maximize the resources so we're
working on that now
we're also working on a new ways of
working projects look at how we can
maximize on home working
and learn the really good points from
what we've done over the last six months
as well as uh teasing out what could
have gone better
um and and putting in place some
processes to make sure that we uh
we use that to the best benefit for
staff and for the council
going forward and we're ongoing flex and
review of arrangements it is very
flexible as you'll be aware
circumstances change the announcements
from government
change every day so we have staff who
currently work in the county but live
outside of the county some of which are
now in local lockdown areas so we're
having to continually think
of all of these arrangements that we
need to put in place for everybody
and just in terms of what we've learned
i think the positive points are that the
workforce has been incredibly adaptable
and resilient
more than we could have um really hoped
for
we've got positive staff who have really
assisted and where we've got the more
vulnerable staff we've been able to
use teams to help and to work with them
we've been able to provide services
throughout we've even improved service
provision in some areas particularly
around
revenues where the number of cases i
think has actually increased where
people can get through the work
quicker um working with different um
technology
from home so that's been a benefit and
we're going to be learning from those
cases we've had a rapid advance in the
use of technology as you'll be aware
from this morning zoom session but
um again sometimes um the
implementation of new technology can
take a while
but with this we really was an overnight
learning curve and we managed to put in
remote and home working technology very
very quickly
there's definitely been an uh we're in
this together culture and i think i can
say that i'm
really proud of all the staff that have
worked
together over the last six months we've
um
they've been fantastic they've looked
after each other
and they've pulled together a hybrid
approach so working from home working on
rotors working
in the office out on the patch to do
everything they can
and i've put three bullet points at the
end there just for something that you
might want to consider
um in your project we we have um
we have agreed that there is no
substitute for face-to-face meetings we
miss
them maybe not as often as we needed as
we used to have them but we do miss that
debate
um that ability to have informal
meetings to to kind of bounce ideas
around
we have had some isolation issues which
i've mentioned earlier
and that kind of building of rapport has
been very valued and we missed that as
well so when we've had new employees
start during the clovid period
um we haven't been able to do the
inductions walk around the buildings
introduce them to other colleagues so
there is no substitute for some of that
stuff and hopefully we'll be able to get
to a good balance in the future and then
amy just following on from that there's
just a few slides to give you some idea
of
how the community supported the team so
lots of thank you letters if you just
want to carry on paging through
um which really helped the staff the
morale
uh was really good they picked them up
they had uh occasionally
a box of biscuits left for them a few
bits and pieces so
yeah they did a fantastic job um that's
the overview
sorry if i've rattled through it i will
make sure you get sent the slides
and i've got some numbers with me as
well which i can also send out to you
so things like the numbers of people
we've looked after in terms of the
vulnerable
the numbers of parcels that we sent out
the stickers on the waste bins
the business support grants got lots of
facts and figures if you're interested
in any of that information as well which
i can send through
but i won't waffle on any more happy to
take any questions
thank you very much do we have any
chance
yeah my counselor jones
sorry
i think i'm on now properly can you hear
me yeah yeah
i think you all did an amazing job and
it's
unbelievable really the work that was
put in and all you have achieved
uh one of the things i felt a little bit
disappointed in
is that i'm at home isolated
doing very little and i could have
helped out and i did offer but nobody
came back to me because i would
quite like to perhaps phone people up
just to give them some reassurance
people were on their own so please don't
forget us if you need
any more help thank you
that's a really interesting comment i
think we could have done
more with the volunteers schemes um as
you say
especially that befriending um part of
the work we found
i think we phoned over 7 000 people um
some of whom
just wanted a daily phone call so i'll
definitely um
take that on board i think it's
definitely something we could implement
uh
in the future so thank you for that i
think if i may if i may
actually that was organized from very
early on
uh you could register with either the
nhs or derbyshire county council i did
register with that
county council and i was helping i was
doing shopping
they were making phone calls so they
were putting us into contact
i think what would have happened with
the district you kind of started by
doing your own thing and i don't mean
that in a bad way because we're very
proactive straight
away but you started doing your own
thing
and it might be the reason why some of
us didn't register with
uh the main area but definitely calling
people who needed a friendly chat
i was able to do that because i
registered with the derbyshire county
council and they have
they had more volunteers than they had
people needing
help so i would suggest that
in future you do encourage everybody to
register
and then if you are if people need you
then
um then it's like a centralized
way of organizing the volunteers uh
arthur was very well organized
from the very beginning
any other questions
no so i've got one question you
mentioned
a bit earlier on in your presentation
about
some specific issues with for example uh
single parents working from home and
we did discuss that as a ca as a
committee that not everybody would have
found that
working from home was really good for
them
so and we're very well aware of that and
as a committee we did say that we wanted
to look at the risks
so one of the risk is obviously the
mental health
of staff especially those who are
like you say single parents etc and and
you did say that you were calling
them uh on a regular basis to make sure
that you were supporting them
so who is we is it the uh support group
that you set up from very early on
or is it the the manager from or for
that person specifically for that member
of staff
so yeah what happened was that each uh
service manager and heads of service
were asked
on regular occurrences really to make
sure that they were in regular contact
with all of their staff
and that they were aware of um how they
were getting on
what the arrangements were for working
from home
there was lots of conversations just
around the operational side of things so
just from doing that the managers were
able to build up a little bit of a
picture
about each member of staff in terms of
their family circumstances
which ones had very young children at
home
particularly i'm aware of two cases i
think where we had
issues where they felt very isolated and
in those cases
um the service managers and also the
head of service was very proactively
involved
um in making sure that that person was
supported as much as possible offering
things like
annual leave to have a bit of a rest
also offering um the ability for them to
come into the office
um and also kind of buddying up with
other people that wanted to come in the
office they were both in on the same day
within the covid uh restrictions but
allowing them
uh um to be able to see other people and
to have conversations
in the office so that was very much done
on a supervisor and head of service
level
um also one of the things that i was
really encouraged by
um and i know a lot of you won't be fans
of facebook or
kind of social media but ins to some
extent if people saw
some of their colleagues struggling on
social media they
reported that in as well so if for
instance somebody was putting a little
bit of a strange message on social media
very late at night about being lonely or
all those kinds of things they were
being picked up by colleagues and then
making sure that that person was phoned
the next day and discussing those
issues with them so it wasn't just a
workplace thing it was more of a
friendship group as well that was set up
and they also used whatsapp in some
some areas so set up working groups in
whatsapp
chat groups to be able to continually
stay in contact
um and having some informal zoom
meetings as well so not just work
based zoom meetings but kind of a coffee
morning to
for people to zoom in with workplace
issues but also
checking up that everybody was was okay
so there's quite a lot done by managers
and heads of service to that
to that extent okay thank you any other
questions
i think we've covered quite quite a lot
so my question personally is uh
obviously we're looking moving forward
going forward how we're going to
uh set up things if we are going to have
more
working from home etc from your point
of view as part of your because one of
the aspects you mentioned
the last comments you made about the
lack of
informal meetings in between and
conversation between members of staff
for which is face to face
is quite crucial in in some areas
and so how do you feel about
moving forward that could be included in
in your in your working from home sort
of policy
how would you make it work yeah we we're
very much
aware that those kind of informal
meetings have got a
great benefit i don't think we realize
that um sometimes you don't realize what
you're missing do you until it's gone so
um we have set up a a working group who
are working through all of those issues
doing a really good job on it so far
working with myself and the other
directors and sarah
to look at how we can take the best bits
of what we've learnt
but also improve on some of the things
that haven't gone so well
um and they're looking at some hybrid
options so how can we get the best of
both worlds
um across both councils because some
teams like environmental health work
across the strategic alliance
they're hoping to come up with some
really practical ideas looking at
technology
looking at rotor systems to come into
the office
safe working environments all of that
especially the i.t side of thing is
going to be a piece of work that's going
to be emerging over the next couple of
weeks
um maybe month or so
we'll be able to update you on that as
part as far as your
piece of work is concerned on a regular
basis because it's a really live ongoing
piece of work
we're very um conscious of the second
wave of covid and it may
mean that we're having to continue like
this for at least another six months
um the prime minister suggested that
people should continue to work from home
recently uh so we are trying to
get the best of both worlds and we're
going to be issuing more information
about that
very soon so i'm sarah and myself i'll
be able to keep you updated on that how
that progresses
great councillor birkin
thank you chair um thanks for asking
answering my next question karen
what i was going to say was it'd be
useful if you could
um record for us what sort of issues
has the pandemic problem shown up in the
existing working from home policy
i think sarah mentioned before that you
sort of had to hit the ground
running because a lot of things were
happening um
very quickly and changing very quickly
uh so you've had to adapt
very very very quickly and it sounds
like you've done that very well from the
information that we've got and
and directly from you today but other
stuff as well
so but what have been going through my
mind is is having had to
um change things very quickly because of
the pandemic
what where what sort of issues with the
existing policy has that shown that
would either working well
or needed to amend it because often
that's a
an opportunity for changing or having to
change a policy
is when something has happened it's only
when um
something as drastic as as clovid
happens that you may realize oh we
didn't have that part of
we didn't have opportunity or
information within the policy to cope
with that because it had never
happened uh it's never come up before
it's that emergency situation
that you mentioned so i'm looking for
some information from
yourself or sarah as to that sort of
point of view as well
um you also mentioned the homework in
survey and that workstation assessment
questionnaire it'll be useful i think
for us to
uh to get that sort of information when
we're reviewing the whole thing as well
if that's possible please
thank you chair
yeah just to answer those it's
definitely possible to get the
information through in the surveys um
in terms of what we've learned from our
home working um current process
sarah might be able to assist in a bit
more detail than
me but um as you say we did jump into it
uh you know with the majority of the
workforce overnight
so we have learned some lessons and i
think particularly around workstations
um making sure that we've got the
telephony set up
properly so that the customer contact
centers and anybody
turning up face-to-face in the customer
contact centers can get the answers
that they need from people at home and
that communication
um needs to be uh very
uh good it needs you know it needs to be
second to none really we can't have
members of the public hanging around
waiting for long periods of time
for their their questions to be answered
but in terms of the practicalities of it
sarah can you add any more to what i've
said
thanks yeah no problem um i think one of
the key things
that we'd look to address drawing it is
to make sure that it isn't overly
bureaucratic
and there aren't you know lots of steps
in there and a massive long policy that
a manager has to read through so it's
it's making sure we get the message
across for in an easier format for
managers and employees to be able to
follow so it doesn't look as
um you know intimidating and put people
off looking at the homework in option
and as karen mentioned it's about
looking at the practicalities
and making sure that we um have
solutions to those but look at a range
of solutions rather than just saying it
has to be that or it has to be this
and so that we're reflecting the needs
of each service area
and so i think those are the key things
moving forward um
that i think we need to include in the
new policy just so that we have got that
inbuilt flexibility in there so that we
can
make those changes but everybody also
knows the core principles that we're
looking to achieve from this so that
if there are any managers or employees
that aren't adhering to those
we have made it clear from the outset
what those expectations are particularly
in relation to
what we were discussing earlier the safe
working environment at home
so that people don't end up with
long-term issues say from sitting on a
certain chair and you end up with a bad
bath
any other questions on this uh
presentation
no well thank you very much and i do
think that uh i agree with the counselor
jones
comments the staff
you have got to be very impressed with
how
very quickly the staff has responded to
the crisis
and how well they all got together to
work very effectively i think over the
last
few months and especially when it comes
to the
itm we've had a few hiccups but that's
to be expected when we've got
big organizations uh but we're getting
there and i think it's
unprecedented circumstances though we've
all kind of
gone a little bit towards making things
uh
better but also being able to actually
still fulfill our duties
either as counselors or men as managers
or as members of staff
under very strange circumstances
and and i think that you know credit has
got to be
given to the staff as well and the hr
department as well because i know
uh sarah would have had to deal with the
daily
changes in the guidance and having to
implement guidance where whereby before
before you might have had a few months
at least to
create new policies for the councils
when new guidance are coming
out of government this time you only had
one day and then you had to implement
them straight away so
i appreciate that the stress and the
circumstances were quite difficult to
start with so
i'm sure i speak on behalf of all
members of this community to say that
thank you and
well done well done thank you
thanks okay thank you karen yeah you're
free to go
and if you want to stay you're welcome
to stay as well but
uh i'm sure you'd have to thank you to
do sarah i'm not sure if
we still need you and sue will be able
to
remind me do we still need sarah for the
rest of the
agenda i don't think we do do it we
don't care no we don't
thank you very much thank you very much
for your help
and we'll be asking you to come and
visit us again very soon and especially
once you have a draft for us yes uh
ready to consider be great
if we could have it and then we could
ask questions and
put comments forward as well as members
of this committee thank you
thank you
so this was quite uh interesting so
we'll just go and move on to the next
item
which is the forward plan for 15 august
to 15 september 2020
we all had a chance to have a look at
the forward plan
do we have any questions or comments
that we want to put forward
no okay
so the next item on the agenda
is the
work program which is page
57 i believe yeah 57
uh well actually it starts on 56
my apologies so we're all happy so
we we've got through the 26th 23rd
of june we've got fourth of august on
29th of september so we've gone through
the agenda for 29th of september
and then on the 3rd of november we've
got some further interviews planned
with the director of corporate services
and head of transformation and
partnerships
uh managers and staff working from home
during the pandemics
so let's hope that we will have a number
of staff uh
agreeing to speak to us uh so if you
could work your magic
for on that because last time i don't
think we had many
wanting to speak to to us apart from
when we had a walk about
and obviously we can't have a walk about
so that's replacing the walkabouts
yes chair i mean that's interesting
isn't it i think possibly the walkabout
might have
done us some favors really because i
think staff realized the
benefit of it so i'm hoping obviously
we'll see what what comes in and then
i'll i'll do a bit of
you know speaking to teams individually
to try and encourage them but
we'll see what we get great thank you
so any comments or questions on the word
it's quite straightforward no
okay so uh the next item
so we happy to move on to the next item
we haven't got any additional urgent
items
and so we just agree the next meeting
which is the 3rd
of november 2020 at 10 a.m which is
the meeting as uh as per our darling
councillor birkin
thank you chair uh just a quickie mostly
to uh
to sue um i think sarah just said in
there
that um this was a longs the the work
from home policy is a long-standing
policy i just wondered if there were any
if there was a protocol or a policy for
reviewing policies
on a regular basis um it's something
that when i was a school governor you're
required to
to do and you ended up trying to do 60
or 70 every
you know every couple years i just
wondered where
if there's anything within our systems
whereby there's a requirement for a
policy to be looked at every
whatever two years or something like
that yes if
i can share yes we do have uh processes
in places that there's a guidance for
how policies
should be reviewed with various things
about
um you know the steps you have to go
through including the one about scrutiny
that you know it has to be offered up to
scrutiny for consideration if they wish
to look at it
so that is available on the internet
um and there is a is a deadline usually
it was on the internet i've not looked
at it recently but i used to trawl
through it quite regularly
and it sets out what the policy is
and when it was you know last reviewed
and when it's reviewed in the future so
it is it is there on the internet
and obviously it varies between the
policies as to the time scale
i think given the pandemic um obviously
things are a little bit more
pressing now so i think there might be a
review of one or two policies uh
depending on how we proceed so
the arrangements are in in place and if
you want to see the actual document i
can send you a copy if you want
okay yes please if you could thank you i
appreciate it
thank you yeah thank you chair
is that all the committee that wants to
see that just council
i'm sure you could you could email it to
all the committee members of the useful
information anyway just to have us
background information anyway thank you
i'll do that chair thank you
thank you so uh we'll
we'll move on to so we close the meeting
here actually because we've got nothing
else on the agenda
the next meeting is on the 3rd of
november
excuse me but just to remind my members
that we did say early on that
uh we would do the questionnaire uh via
email so if you think of any questions
that we want to ask the staff
uh let's get a few questions ready uh in
advance and send to
if you could copy all members of the of
the committee that would be quite useful
as well
okay well thank you very much for your
attendance
and we'll see you all again very soon
take care
thank you
you